that's it i was like my career is over i
had like no confidence or no i was like
a
shell of like my former self
you don't often get to hear about the
real human
implications of cancer culture you don't
get to hear how it
feels for the recipient you don't get to
see
how it plays out in the moment my next
guest
he can tell you jack maynard was caught
in the middle of a well-known
well-documented british council culture
moment when something that he had said
almost 10 years earlier
resurfaced while he was at the peak of
his powers
while he was fulfilling his dream while
he was in the middle of filming
i'm a celebrity get me out of here a
couple of years ago and the events that
would unfold following that council
culture moment would change him
forever ptsd anxiety depression
shame he even remarked today that there
was a high chance he wasn't going to
make it to this podcast because some of
those symptoms still remain
i guess the question is how do you pick
yourself up from something like that
how do those moments feel what actually
happens when you're told while you're
in the middle of the jungle in australia
filming a show
that the outside world has turned
against you
these are the things you can only learn
from hearing the truth from someone
that's been through those situations
so without further ado my name is
stephen bartlett and this is the diver
ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
so jack um i did a lot of research on
you and your your background what you're
into
the work you do and your sort of
professional endeavors are quite
eclectic
that you know it's hard to pin down
whether you consider yourself to be
a youtuber now yeah or a dj yeah
or something else so i wanted to despite
all the research i wanted to ask you
like i'm not a fan of like labeling
oneself
how do you how do you classify yourself
i still do describe myself
as a youtuber like to everyone on me i
kind of say oh yeah you know i do
youtube and
you still to this day get a look of like
which mean you
do youtube that's your job but i think
like you said there's kind of a
collective of things i do and when i
kind of break it down
to everything i do they yeah like kind
of
fully understand now like very recently
as well people have only just started to
understand like what it actually
is in that youtube and just social media
itself can be
obviously a job so yeah i still go for
youtube that's why
you don't post as much as you used to on
youtube
no mainly because
literally at the beginning of last year
i decided right i want to go kind of
bigger productions a lot like a lot of
the music videos i've done and
things like that and i just want to kind
of get out there like other i
kind of really want to just get loads of
like celebrities and like reality tv
stars on my
channel and do loads of fun things in
places like you know
all over the world with them and then
obviously kind of covert came in because
i was just at a point where i was
so like honestly like sick to death of
filming videos at home like in my flight
you know i was honestly just
beyond board and i had so many other
things i was doing as well you have i
think you i think i saw four videos this
not many is it considering i was
uploading
once or twice a week yeah before but
yeah like i said i really just
kind of couldn't face doing those kind
of videos and
for me youtube's always been something i
enjoy so much and my best videos are
honestly the videos i've kind of enjoyed
making the most what's the like the
you know people will look at youtubers
especially especially young kids and
they think oh god i'd love to be a
youtuber i think i read a report that
said
um one of the especially in the the
western world in the uk one of the
jobs that people aspire to young kids
aspire to the most gen z
is to become a youtuber yeah but i'm
sure and i know because i've spoken to a
lot of youtubers that
there's a lot of um adverse side effects
of the job yeah definitely i think well
the first thing is
people think it's obviously like people
do think it's easy
100 you know you get to sit around
making silly videos in their eyes i
think if you ask
you know 100 people probably 80 of them
would probably say are they just going
to sit around making
like stupid videos they don't see a lot
of the stuff kind of that goes into it
but it's definitely not easy you know
there's no guarantee that you're going
to do well on it you have no idea if you
do
well on it how long that will last and
all like you know there's all those kind
of things and it's just
a lot of pressure because it's not like
uh cool i know
i'm gonna do these every week i'm gonna
get paid like x amount this is gonna be
my job this could be my career like
you're on a salary site
no you could you know you could put all
your time and effort into it and maybe
like money into
certain things you're trying to do and
if it doesn't pay off
it's definitely and the algorithm
changes yeah well things are changing on
it
constantly you've got to really like
kind of try and
keep up yeah exactly it's anxious yeah
you can have a month where you do really
bad or you upload a certain video that
you're really proud of and it does
really bad and you're just like
oh god why is that and then you kind of
fall back to your safety net of things
that you know
maybe will do well but you don't want to
do those anymore and it's just like a
yeah it's very hard and i think it does
affect
people in like many different ways some
people kind of love that and they love
the challenge you want to keep on going
which is amazing but
yeah like i said there are people who
want to do this one thing
which can do incredibly well and then it
switches and it suddenly doesn't do well
anymore
not through any fault of their own but
just because youtube have kind of
decided yeah we want to see
more stuff like this and they can push
all that kind of content in yeah people
can get incredibly bad like mental for
me and i think people are very vocal
about that now
as well which is which is amazing so
it's really good but i think yeah
especially
obviously all youtubers are pretty much
like self-employed so
if you are doing very well and then one
minute it drops and that's it
i remember frankie cacosa said yeah do
you know frankie yeah
he's from brighton yeah frankie said to
me one day i'm sure he won't mind me
saying
this that um obviously after all the
fame he had a fairly young age x factor
he did a couple of other shows
and then the money dried up yeah and he
was like well i can't go and work at
[ __ ] tesco now
because yeah i just like an ego still
yeah it has the money but the ego is
kind of still there in a way
i see that with youtubers a lot i think
i think they because they've
they've been in the public spotlight and
they've built fame
yeah you know or notoriety in whatever
way they then feel like they
they can't go and have a normal life
because yeah fame your
your family is fairly famous i'd say
yeah relatively
yeah yeah i heard your your grandpa your
grandparent your granddad
your dad were also singers yeah so my
grandad i i don't know like
too much about it so i know my dad
appreciated like west end when he was
younger
kind of like a kid but you might still
be making that up there you know give
him
up i have no evidence of this i used to
be a football player
but they did that and then yeah my
granddad as well was like a kind of like
stage singer
and things like that um so i think
that's probably where my brother gets it
from
that's for sure and i guess he's had
like the most fame out of all of us
um but yeah he kind of started on he's
the more
you know traditional like famous like
pop star whatever you want to call it
but
he kind of yeah the same as me side on
youtube and he's kind of like back to
that now as well has kind of gone
full circle so he's kind of back on
there and how was that when when he i've
got
two brothers i know people ask you a lot
and i've seen them ask you a million
times like are you jealous of your
brother or like whatever but um
how was that when he started to get a
little bit more
well-known um and you're a younger
brother
yeah he's two years older than me so
i've got two older brothers as well so i
can relate
okay but i can't relate to them being
famous yeah to be honest it was there
like honestly was no jealousy because i
think one i was so young like
i was literally sitting in school just
finishing school like leaving school
he was like kind of yeah relatively
famous got signed all of this so he's
doing that really well
great money coming in like moved to
london all these things so it was just
like
so cool feels like so cool to just be
around all of that stuff and just
experience it all with him and it was
kind of more again i said not
jealousy but i like saw i just saw that
opportunity there i was like
there must be something yeah i can do
even if it's like working for my brother
somehow doing something
god knows what it would have been but
like i knew i could have
kind of figured something out and just
conveniently
my brother like basically broke up with
his girlfriend
she moved out and he was like oh do you
want to come and live in london with me
i was like yes yes obviously i wouldn't
do that absolutely
so i made a deal with my brother because
he kind of knew he was like
i was always arming and hiring about
starting youtube
he was like well let's make a deal this
was the best deal
kind of much ever made in my life in a
way because i'll let you live in london
with me
rent free but you have to like you know
promise
your maker and put out a youtube video
once a week
every week just why did he say that to
you because i think he like
it just needed he needed to like
incentive for me that i
am like actively like working and i'm at
the same time i'm still trying to find
other work in london but it's like he
wanted me to
live with him like he did he did he kind
of like needed me to live with him in a
way
but at the same time yeah he didn't want
me just living there rent-free
sure living it up doing nothing
so yeah it was like a pretty good deal
and
very fortunately for me i couldn't
really pinpoint why but yeah my youtube
like
took off really really fast after about
kind of two months
of doing youtube i didn't really need to
find a job anymore i was making like
more than enough money
to kind of carry on and luckily he was
like really good friends with people
like
well and then so was i at this point
like casper joe sugg
all of these who were you know oh geez
oh geez
huge at this time so we all just kind of
started filming
you know every video like all together
is like a big group and then it just
like yeah really like blew up from there
so the golden days lucky yeah definitely
definitely the golden days
that's for sure bro yeah it was everyone
talks about those moments like alfie
does the same and
i know josh i've met him a few times
yeah it's fair to say it was so much
easier then
like i could sit at home and film some
weird game with my friends and get like
three million views
in like a week just off that one video
so it was just like wow now if i did
that it wouldn't yeah i wouldn't
do the same so this is when i got to the
point where i was like right i wanna
do like something different from all the
others i don't wanna come up the next
youtube idea i kind of wanna
break ground in terms of like
tv and and youtube tv
yeah your first experience on tv
mainstream tv
was that your celeb yeah how did you
feel you get the phone call
um i didn't think it was and i honestly
did not think i was gonna get on it
whatsoever but i was like let's
definitely go to that meeting you know
the whole thing of let's see
so they can see my face and they're like
we'd love to just chat to you about
something
you're going to need just called me in
flight a meeting
and i don't know what it was that day i
remember leaving the meeting thinking
either they're just like really nice and
good at acting all that one like so well
um i just like kind of felt like i was
on fire that day i
got in there like nothing to lose i was
like i'm not gonna get it but this will
be
you know i was more thinking cool maybe
next year
then the next one then i like will get
on if i carry on and do all this kind of
stuff was it an audition
it wasn't an audition it was just a
meeting you met like the
like the casting people i guess
and i know a few of my friends had also
met them i think like casper and stuff
had also met them
it was like two months i just had the
meeting i never told anyone for some
reason
like again like i said because i just
didn't think it was gonna happen
and then the boys oh yeah this like
meeting as well and i was like oh
oh well you went there then i was like
we got told like a couple of weeks ago
that uh you know it's not going to go
any further
but thanks for coming in and i was like
oh i haven't got that called i didn't
say i think
i'm pretty sure that hasn't happened
unless my manager hasn't told me or
something
and literally it's like the next day
they called oh we really want to meet
jack again
and i think i met them i can't really
remember me
this one was more just sort of like a
kind of how it all goes if i do do it
and literally like the next day
they're like cool we want jack to do it
can you do it i was like obviously
obviously i can do it i was so scared
though because i'm actually like
terrified of
bugs so i was so excited and i was like
this is it
could you you couldn't tell people for a
while right no i couldn't obviously i
did
but i was just like i think i was like
so scared i was like how
the hell has this happened but the one
thing i will say i didn't is and this is
like
bad obviously i did when i knew i was
doing it but i never actually really
watched the show before
obviously i completely knew what it was
but i didn't realize how big the show
was
i didn't realize at that time it was
arguably the biggest show
like in the country yeah between like
that like kind of
strictly things like they're all like
battling out for
number one so yeah i just kind of
prepared myself for it all like i said i
was
i was feeling great going into it i was
feeling like really good
how much notice did you get between
knowing where you were on the show i
think i actually knew for like
a while i must have known for like a
couple of months
i remember getting there and people like
i found out literally like a couple of
weeks ago really
i was i knew for like ages because i
said i guess they knew they were getting
youtuber on like
the end of the season before they're
like oh next year we need a youtuber or
something
so you flew to australia yeah i'd done
all my stuff i was feeling good
flew to australia and i was the first
one to get there
so i was there for a week like no phone
and i was an idiot because
i said i was in the jungle people were
telling me like oh did you not just
bring another phone and like hide it and
i was like
obviously i was too scared to do that so
i was like oh no they didn't do that
yeah everyone did all the other guests
they just had another phone with them
somewhere in their suitcase
so they were just like talking to a
friend i guess whatever like
no i didn't know who else was there at
the time but when i was in the camp
while they were in the jungle no no no
they were like in the like kind of
like the locked downy kind of thing
before you were shot in a hotel room
for a week and you didn't have to see
anyone
and you're like jet lagged as well but
luckily the lady who's looking after me
yeah she just i could not leave my room
without her being next to me but she was
really nice like we got along so well so
i was really happy with that
and every morning at breakfast she's
like oh you know another one's got here
and everyone's got here
and she wouldn't tell me who it was but
she'd give me clues and then i was like
oh
it was just annoying i was like i wonder
how my social media is going
again because that's just what my thing
was like an everyday thing for me i
posted every day i do all these things
it was so weird not checking it
i was like look let's make a deal i kind
of deal with you there was no deal in my
heart
not my mom but you know we do me a favor
just
have to don't say anything you just go
on my instagram and let me
look at like what's been uploaded and
let me just see it's going well and i
think at the time i was averaging like
40 to like 60 000 likes
so it's going like pretty well and then
she's like yeah but you can't look at
the comments or anything they might be
saying who's in there i was like deal
and i didn't actually look but i was
looking to my photos and i was getting
like 250 000 likes i was like
what and that's when i realized how big
the show was like
that moment i was like oh my god just
from being announced
yeah like it's just gone crazy and i was
thinking
you know maybe they're making a bit of a
like it probably is
causing debate like oh this youtuber is
he is celebrity is he not
and i was like welcoming that because i
was like let's get more people like
talking about me he gets my name out
there more
so that's when i was like oh my god this
is massive i need to win this
i need to i need to win this what was
your strategy because i've always
thought if i ever got into a reality tv
show i'd be like
how do i not be a prick like for me it
was just on it like
to be honest at that point i had like
no anxiety no stresses i was not
scared at all i wasn't even nervous like
nerves never hit me that was always one
of my strengths i found
so i was just yeah i was like confident
not so much coming down i'm gonna win
but i'm just so confident that
you know i know i can go in there and
come across like
fine i know i know i won't go on there
and be like a horrible
person or whatever that's just not who i
am so
yeah i was confident and went in there
first couple of days of filming with
everyone
just felt like great like so natural i
guess
i kind of knew what was going on a
little bit because we got partnered up
straight away and i was obviously the
youngest
i was the youngest person on there i was
the youngest guy and then toff was the
youngest girl
then we got partnered it was like the
people at home
voted who was together so i just kind of
saw where that was like going it was
like cool so they're trying to
do that kind of story so you're way
there
so i think to realize i think she's like
a very
smart girl i didn't ever play a
character it was like play the most
entertaining version of yourself the
whole time
i'm just like yeah kind of giving the
people what they want and i knew she was
doing the same
as well like she read into the situation
and i remember thinking i was like oh
it's going to be
it sounds really mean for the other
people on there but i was like i have
like a feeling maybe it's going to be
between like
me and her or i think we'll both do like
really well if we keep
as we're going just like little things
like you realize we were just maybe
saying the most like kind of jokes
between everyone and like we were maybe
the most like just
having the most like like fun with it a
lot of people were quite stressed and
stuff
but we're having like a lot of fun um
and then yeah obviously it took like a
massive
turn i don't know what you're talking
about
if you don't that's fine congratulations
yeah
no one knows they're going to say what
happened next
um i mean i don't think i'm allowed to
get
too into in terms of like what happened
but it's like in terms of
i won't tell anyone cause i was there
in the morning like super early i mean
it must have been like
6 a.m so i'm like 5 6 a.m
and there's like a rule like two people
always need to be in the camp at one
point and
they were calling the you know the
voices of
god the person on the microphone was
like calling people to go and do
something like oh you need to go down
there
i realized i was on my own and i was
like i swear this isn't allowed
but i was like oh well maybe you know
we've been in here
a few days now they're like loosening up
and whatever you know we're all adults
here i'm sure i'll be fine type thing
and say oh jack can you come to like the
medical hut
i was like okay and i had two things on
my mind
first being i had like a tick the day
before right
and so i was like oh maybe they're just
checking in on that or
this is like really depressing i was
like oh here we go because they always
in the show kind of pull someone to the
side and they have like kind of like a
secret mission-y type thing oh yeah they
do in the show there's always someone
who has to do something without anyone
else knowing
is this that oh maybe it's that so i was
like going there like really
quite excited intrigued and then i went
in there just like all the producers and
stuff
and i was like this doesn't look very
good i was like
what i was taking out with like no
explanation whatsoever i had no idea
you weren't given a next i was not told
for like
four hours i got taken out and the hotel
was like four hours away
and pretty much until i got my phone
which is the hotel which was that far
away
i didn't know anything they just said it
was like oh something online i was like
wow that
was really oh that narrows it down like
my whole life's online this is something
something
something i'm online i'm just thinking
like absolutely like worst case
scenarios of what could like possibly
happen to
a young guy on tv because i was thinking
all kinds of things
like it's weird like you're sitting
there thinking of things i know i've
never
done in my life but i'm like oh god
someone never said something yeah
someone said something or made something
up or i don't know you're just thinking
the worst
and you're panicking and then i mean it
was like the weirdest
you get back to your friend yeah i get
back to the hotel room
finally and i get my phone and my
phone's like
so crazy and then well i think like the
next day i realized they'd actually like
announce me being taken out before they
took me out
so like my i mean yeah everyone knew why
i'd left
but i didn't so i was seeing things on
my phone i was like what the hell
just like everyone was just like you
know i hope you're okay like i can't
believe this
and all that and i'm like oh my god i
don't know what to do i don't want to
look at it i'm like kind of standing in
my eyes closed like my phone's man
[Music]
i don't know what to do but two calls i
need to make here
i've got a call from my brother and then
like a thousand from my manager
so i call my manager and it's like
my manager lawyers the ceo
and everyone there's everyone of any
importance
in my life is on that call and yeah
let's find out you know this is
something that's been going on for like
nearly a week in the papers and stuff of
like
tweets and everything like this and
obviously i'm in there i don't have a
phone so i have no control i can't say
anything
how are you feeling then i was like
crying
i was like oh i was like all over the
place i was
i was just so frustrated that's what it
was i was
so frustrated and like angry why
i don't know i just felt this could have
all
some they were sitting on the like they
were sitting on this for
a while these tweets and stuff i just
know it because it was deleted
long before i went on this show like a
year before i even went on the show they
didn't exist anymore
because they were awful it was stupid
so i kind of got rid of them when i was
kind of coming up on youtube as i wanted
to first see my management made me do
that like cool let's go for everything
and lee anything you've said that is
just idiotic and i was like we should
definitely
definitely do that so i knew i'd had
twitter since i was like
15 14 or something so it didn't have to
get to the point where i was taken out
to then have to address it all i wish i
could have before
i even went on or after or or just after
kind of late
yeah like stuck with it and kind of adds
more drama to it
yeah it just made it look it made it
look worse
they said oh jack wanted to leave and
address it and i do feel like i did need
to address it as soon as possible
don't get me wrong but i mean yeah i
didn't say yeah i should
i should leave here and and
and address these things so just
frustrating and yeah so i spoke to my
management we kind of went over
everything and like
what happens now and it's like do you
want us to come
australia no i just want to come home
then
cause i was like although i knew i'd
done like bad things
how it was all handled like i had like
hatred at that point
at that moment in time anyway for the
people
that were involved like in the show that
were like near me but i said i was so
frustrated so i don't want to be here
no way i want to come home then if this
if this is it and i'm this is done
then i'm coming home what is the point
of me being here
right yeah might as well come home so oh
that was a range i was literally a
flight in like
three hours or something so i just like
legged it so yeah paul
yeah again i hadn't like looked at my
phone i hadn't looked at anything
and i opened whatsapp twitter instagram
like nothing
i still don't really know the extent
of what's happened and then like yeah i
called my brother
he was like speechless as well but he
could but again like he'd kind of been
i said it's been going on for a week so
he's been on the phone type
my management and stuff for like you
know days and days and days going
through all of this kind of
trying to help i don't know i don't know
really what they were asking him or how
he could kind of help but they were like
you know
they don't reach out to you don't say
anything don't comment on anything don't
do any of these things and he was like
trying to help in
whatever way he could did you worry that
it might have an impact on him
yeah when i spoke to him that was kind
of one of my
first thoughts to be honest i felt like
i just like [ __ ] it for everyone
like i said at this point i didn't
really know and then we were talking
about it he felt like you know this is
my time to shine and all of this it
could have been like
life-changing if i'd have like let's
just say i went on like one could have
been yeah
life-changing it was but
not in the right way and then he was
like have you looked online or anything
and i was like no i don't want to
i was like scared and he was like oh and
i think you should like have a look i
was like why he's like look just hang up
have a look online and stuff go on
twitter
so it did when i went online and twitter
to be honest like all i saw was like
support
for me because it was a thing of
everyone knew what i said was very
stupid very naive me like really bad
but you know people also knew
what i was gonna say people have kind of
been there themselves people understood
that okay yeah he was like
a kid at the time i was actually like
still in school and these things that
happened
it was before i had any kind of like
following i didn't want
you know the jack of today to be
you know known as the jack of like when
i was 15 i fully understand
this is like one of the conversations i
had with my mum i like accept when i was
like
15 16 whatever i wasn't a very nice like
kid i was pretty like
bad i was like kind of a naughty kid i
guess
so people like understood that you're an
idiot but at the same time
we feel kind of like sorry that this has
come back to like bite me on the ass you
know
like seven years later or something in
that moment when you go online and you
see everybody
like the world you know it must feel
like the world is ending to some degree
yeah
what are your thoughts about your future
in that moment and like oh
i thought that was it i was like that
that's it i was like my career
is over but i also wasn't thinking oh
what am i going to do
but i was just like i don't care about
what i'm going to do now but
i reckon that's it but then also when i
saw online and like the amount of
support
i mean it was like ridiculous it's like
trending number one like
twitter and all of these things but it
was just like huge in the amount of
celebrities that were like in my corner
or whatever you want to say
it's like very overwhelming the weirdest
one i saw was like katie hopkins i was
like
she was like oh don't worry jack you're
an angel compared to me because
obviously she was on the show and like
nothing
i was like that's not the person
i don't know behind you there's like
donald trump and katie hopkins
everyone was just very divided i think
it was a
to sum it up you know i apologize loads
of times on tv
on my youtube channel in like newspapers
and everything
what's the silver lining oh my god i
like to think i probably actually won't
go anything
won't go through anything as bad as that
ever again like
the toll it kind of took on me
like my mental health and everything but
that didn't kind of come until like
a year after because i think like i said
although i was very upset and
everything i kind of brushed it all
under the rug
type thing and just put on like a happy
face ah you know what whatever
kind of time to get on with it but me it
was like i've definitely learned
a lot from this like i know now what
is and like absolutely isn't like
acceptable and
how to like deal with those things and
like move forward and just how to face
horrendous situations like that and like
i
said
hold my hand up and fully take
like the blame obviously but it was just
like
did you pick ptsd i think i read that
somewhere yeah so it was like
um so i've gone full
gun hoe on huel and from having you know
a little bit of an eye at the data
it seems that i'm not the only one in
times when we know that we're going to
get our lives back and we're potentially
going to be
having a great british summer rebound
there's a lot of people like me right
now that are piling in to heal
um i'm doing a few things i'm having
fuel i have at least
two or three heals a day of the ready to
drink berry flavor but i'm
also doing meal prep and so now my diet
is
fuel which is super convenient and it
makes sure that i'm hitting a lot of the
things in terms of like vitamins and
minerals that i'm not getting from my
other food
and my meals and for me that is the
perfect combination
did you pick ptsd i think i read that
somewhere yeah so it was like
um so like i said i wasn't facing it for
ages
and then like a year later or like 18
months later
yeah i just started feeling like awful
like really
anxious like all the time and like just
super like depressed but at the time i
didn't know
it was that i just felt really weird i
was like what the hell
is wrong with me i didn't even like go
for like dinner with my friends without
like wanting to like desperately leave
and i'm feeling like so uncomfortable
like
like my safe place was like at my home i
just wanted to be at home became like a
bit of an introvert because i didn't
want to
do anything it massively affected my
work in terms of i just couldn't
face going to any kind of like meetings
or anything doing any kind of
work it would like for me to do that i'd
literally have to like
i was like going through hell just to do
like just to go to like a meeting or
something i had no idea what it was
i was very quiet about it i never like
spoke to anyone
which was obviously making it worse and
then
how did it feel though in terms of it
was like it felt like a lack of
motivation
yeah it was just like i didn't want to
do anything i didn't want to have to
face doing those things i
basically now looking back and it had
like a complete loss of confidence i
kind of felt like i wasn't
good enough to do any of these things i
was like a shell of like my former self
like i said before i had like
nothing i was so excited to do that show
i was kind of going in there to win it
and everything whereas now
at that point if they asked me oh my god
even if i hadn't been on it type thing
before myself at the same they asked me
to probably have to be like i don't
think i can do it
because i don't think i've had it in me
to kind of push through
and then yeah eventually my friends kind
of clocked on like okay something's
really wrong and i think they kind of
knew it was my brother's been through it
before like really badly before me
it was like him and a few others and
things kind of like yeah like oh
sat me down and yeah it's kind of like
opened up
to everyone what did they notice
i was just like not myself like i said i
was
like one of them one of the main ones i
remember was on my friend josh's
birthday and i had this thing of like
because i knew i would always want to
like not go and leave these like
events or dinners or whatever i'd go
early
it's like 20 minutes early so i can kind
of get there they sit at the table
and just like calm down type thing
essentially i was having like an anxiety
attack pretty much like
once i got there when i was on the way
so i get there and i kind of get past it
and then
like get on with my night type thing and
hopefully feel a bit better
but most of the time i'd get there and
i'd leave before and i'd just text them
some weird excuse oh i've got to do this
ah this has come up sorry i've got to go
home
or i'd pretend like i never went oh yeah
no i'm just not feeling great not going
to come
so they were just like what the hell is
going on like and jack the jungle
yeah no like no way i was like the
life of the party in a way kind of thing
i was up for doing everything and
anything you could like
couldn't stop me type thing but take me
back to the intervention you said your
friends had like yesterday and sat you
down your brother had messaged you yeah
yeah so
i you know kind of explained it uh all
of them again i still kept it like
pretty
close friends and my manager because
she needed to understand i didn't want
to have to keep lying
basically i don't know i think because
she's been in the industry i think she
probably knew
what it was as well it's very common
and that's why i realized when i spoke
to my friends because they were just
like
basically yeah like you know it's very
like normal everyone like has it
because at the time i said i knew my
brother had it before what's it
just like anxiety like depression
like everything but i didn't i just
didn't want to
accept those things i didn't understand
i didn't i hadn't really done any
research i didn't really understand
when i spoke to my friends i then yeah
understood what it was
and although everyone's is very
different from different things and
and it's caused by different things like
different triggers or whatever
it's also like very much the same people
deal with it in different ways of course
but it is
it's like the same like feeling and
overwhelming feeling and stuff so when
they kind of explain that you know
they've all had it and
my brother was like really good with it
because i said he he'd had that anxiety
like really bad he's probably still like
he still does
i still do i don't you don't doesn't
just disappear but you learn
to to deal with it and yeah just having
that conversation
it's like cliche as it sounds just
talking to people about it made me feel
so much better like unexplainably better
so uh and then yes and then there was
just like kind of a
gap between of like nothing just kind of
same old probably doing a bit more work
but at the same time still wasn't
feeling great but i think it had kind of
like calmed down a bit and i'd figured
out little ways to deal with it
and then yeah sas
wanted me that was like what channel is
that uh channel four
channel four call you in there yeah yeah
i want jack to do you're up
sas i hadn't done any tv since when you
find out how do you feel
i was like terrified but i think i would
have it anyway
because like sas is a it's crazy
that is like the craziest show i mean
correct me if i'm wrong but i'd
probably say it's the hardest show there
is
like it is the hardest show there is to
do so i was just i remember thinking
like why do i always get these like
really hard shows why can't i just
go on like celeb juice or something like
that so i'm gonna sit there for the
evening
i was like okay what the hell am i going
to do here because
i just know in the back of my head i'm
thinking i'm saying yes all these things
i'm just
trying to do i'm like yes why not and
you know they
explained it to me as you know they were
pretty black and white about it like
this want this to be
like his big tv come back and all of
this
and i knew that was going to be
um a massive part of my storyline i was
like
oh god because i know i'm going to say
yes to do this and i'm going to want to
not do it i don't want to do it but you
can't
turn down something like this can't turn
down a show that big
so obviously i've said yes and i'm going
through with it
and then yeah kind of gets the point
where like
my anxiety and everything and like my
panic is like
i mean the worse it's ever been i didn't
even want to leave
my house and just yeah straight away my
manager's like i think it's time to see
a therapist where was this in terms of
the run-up to the show
um where it got the worst it's ever been
i'd say like two months before
the show started yes filmed in like
november okay
it was like yeah pretty like
september-ish it was like so bad
so i was like yeah i think you're right
i probably i probably should i've never
been to the therapist before so i was
anxious about that in itself which was
really weird
like speaking time i'm feeling like you
wanna like
feel like you're gonna want you want to
like die in this room because it's just
so
yeah i don't even know like what i was
thinking at the time to be honest with
you but
it was just horrible so yeah
being therapist like three four times a
week doing all this just trying to
like figure it out before on the show
and then she's just like yeah it sounds
like you've got
like ptsd basically and i was like what
other when i hear that i just think of
like the army yeah pretty much i was
like
yeah i think that's like quite dramatic
i was like i don't even feel like
qualified to be labels or something like
that because
i'm not getting like shot at somewhere
like yeah yeah how
then she just yeah like explained it to
me and
one of my like worst things was
basically it made me feel like
physically ill like i always feel like
i'd want to leave because it made me
feel like i was like throw up or
something like there and then i felt
like i was like
holding it but it was like yeah really
really bad like
you can't imagine like how bad it was
and then the best thing that she did was
she went this book it was called the
idiot brain and it explains
how your body reacts to the feeling of
like anxiety and like depression
and let you know the whole fight or
flight type thing and it basically just
completely broke it down
as to why i feel everything i do
whilst it's happening and that like
again
like i said when i spoke to my friends
it made me feel like oh just that one
thing yeah it was like the biggest way
and that was
it was the same kind of thing i was like
now i understand why these things are
happening
and it's not like what was the key thing
you took from that book in terms of just
like a basic principle it was
honestly this like the science behind it
yeah
it explained like the signals like your
brain
sending out to like your stomach and
stuff because it's like
it's a you're in a sense of panic it's
like imagine you walk around you're
about to get hit by a car
and you had like loads of adrenaline
type thing after just like that so it's
a massive sense of panic and your body
wants to like
get out of something get away from a
situation
they use examples from like the caveman
time so it's like your body is like
sensing danger though there is none and
this is kind of a whole problem with it
like nothing's really happening you're
just
scared of like nothing yeah you know
usually you do kind of get through it
and you're
it's like fine but past memories
relating it to trauma situations right
yeah so just like
yeah pretty much just like that's why it
was like a ptsd thing for me because
i felt in a similar situation
as when like the whole i'm a celeb thing
happened really
i said at the time i didn't even know if
it was that but when she kind of broke
it down to me
when do you think it will start and it
just made so much sense for it to be
because of that like it was all around
work
in like certain situations that all
similar to
to then because i'd kind of go to you
know say an event i just
yeah you'd feel like i'm known as the
kid you got kicked off mm-hmm i'm misled
anywhere i'd go that that would always
you know people would always be
kind of talking about it i honestly
before then i probably would not have
been able to do this and like there's a
high chance i'd have like cancelled
last minute like last minute because i'd
be like oh i can do it i can do it never
come to the time and i'll be like
no way i can't even like get in the car
and
drive here but it was just yeah and it
would explain
why yeah your body is literally feeling
that way and it's just because it was
like oh
it makes you feel incredibly nauseous
and stuff because your body is like
scared and tense in danger and things
you need to escape a situation
so it like your bod like the last thing
your body's worried about is like
digesting something
so i always had the singles i was like i
never wanted to eat when i was anxious
yeah i would not be thinking about
eating i wouldn't even get hungry though
yeah but i would just not eat anything
like the whole day i
lost like loads of weight from it as
well one of the most important quotes i
i i read in the book lost connections
was um
as a society we used to think that like
mental health disorders like ptsd and
anxiety depression were a consequence of
like
something broken in you yeah but in fact
everything you've described goes back
ten thousand years to like
savannah and africa are lines running at
me yeah i'm like i need my body to get
ready for me
yeah yeah and so there's there's nothing
the human body is working perfectly fine
in fact the most more important question
is like what's happened to you
and like cause yeah and that's and
that's where that's where my perspective
on mental health disorders shifted
because
i didn't believe that um when i looked
at the data and there's this huge rise
in mental health disorders yeah
and i know that like human beings aren't
evolving anymore we're not changing
anymore
so you think okay if there's a rise in
the the data what has changed to cause
that and then you think okay well the
only thing that's really fundamentally
changed is the world we live in
we start looking at the world we live in
and you say how how has that changed you
say well you know
15 years ago the average american would
say they had three people they could
turn to in a time of crisis they now
said they have zero
we're now living in these white walls
between our loan tapping screens we're
not speaking to friends
and all of these factors which are
conducive with like positive mental
health have now been slowly torn away i
mean the lock down is a great example of
like
extreme and then there was a study which
i talked about in my book where
if you get an animal and you put it in a
cage and you take away
um any uh companionship you take away
all other animals of its type
and you take away the ability for it to
exercise and you take away
anything that might give it stimulation
and then you give it the choice
of drinking heroin water or normal water
they all become drug addicts and uh if
you if you reintroduce like a running
wheel and another rat for it to be with
it doesn't it doesn't become a drug
addict it doesn't choose the hair and
water
and so what you're describing is like
the same as all the guests that have sat
here with me is there's
there's this key moment which is caused
trauma and that's um
and i think that's really empowering for
people to know that yeah you know it's
not
it's something that's happened right and
you can address it from that perspective
as opposed to just throwing drugs at it
thinking that something's broken
yeah but tell me about the therapy
process because i've not had therapy
before but i've always
i've always been intrigued by it at my
company we had a
therapist for all of our team members
yeah and i would definitely have therapy
i think i probably should
but what how was that process and did it
help um
it was like it was strange it may it did
make me feel
a lot better like i said for me i think
this is just who i am i think some
people love talking
about things and just getting it off
their chest and it helps them that way
for me it was just the understanding
once i understood it and
then like i said i figured out ways to
kind of deal with it as well i don't
think it ever goes away if you just
figure out ways to
to deal with it i think if i'd got an
uber here i'd have probably actually
been like more
nervous i don't think i wouldn't cancel
but i'm not at that level but i would
have still probably been a bit more like
how come kind of i don't know i think so
you're not doing it
for me i love being like distracted so
i'd always say like
like tiktok for instance is like the
perfect app for that i always found
because it was like it's really quick
and it's like funny and like it would
always like kind of put
it was always just really funny kind of
put me in a good mood it's like really
quick
so if i was in an uber i'd try and do
something like that or watch some like
youtube videos and just keep
my mind off kind of what i'm going to do
and jack before wouldn't didn't have
that
yet no way i'd have been honestly when
my brother
would like talk about like his anxieties
and like when he'd feel weird i wouldn't
want to come do anything i'd like
be like what are you talking about right
it was literally like just get over it
come on you'll be fine that was like the
classic thing like oh come on you'll be
fine like what could possibly go wrong
but in his mind he's like
listing all the things that go wrong
just you think of the worst case
scenario pretty much
so um yeah once i kind of understood it
a lot more
and had my reasons
like which helped me kind of get over it
a little bit
i then did kind of stop seeing her this
was all
very close like for sure the show i kind
of stopped once the show
started for instance um i haven't been
back since because i think
like i will happily say that like
at doing sas like saved me somehow it
gave me like a new
lease of life um not like i said not
saying it's gone away by any means but
i just a thing there of thinking i mean
if i can do
this and this being at like six o'clock
in the morning
jumping out of a helicopter backwards
into literally like
freezing cold water in the middle of
winter in scotland
i can definitely go and do a podcast or
something like that and that's kind of
like what i like lived by and i still
think of it sometimes i'm like oh my god
jack come on
when i was like at my and at that point
i was honestly at my absolute
worst like the night before as i got
there i got to scotland
and like the morning of i tried to like
pull out
they took again when we got there they
took our phones off because we baked
that you know just can't
we see everyone who's on the show so we
can't text people oh guess who's in the
show and then they like eat the stories
or whatever
he doesn't go out until maybe i was like
i kind of need like i can quit
yeah i need my phone call my manager i'm
not doing it
and the best thing that happened that
they took my phone otherwise i would
have
pulled out i guarantee it but um
they had like therapists on the show
that i would like i'd spoken
quite a bit before and i was very open
with them and they kind of knew
i mean everyone going on they definitely
had their struggles and they had their
their battles and i'm not saying mine's
worse than than anyone but i was
definitely like
very like vocal about mine and was said
i'm not saying it's worth anyone else's
but i was like this is the worst it's
ever been for me
like this is the worst i've ever been so
prepare yourselves for me to be like a
nightmare
and yeah like i said i didn't not i like
people say like i didn't get a second to
sleep
then i thought i literally didn't i just
sat there like seriously
like freaking freaking out and i was
just like what the hell am i gonna do
and i knew he had to leave at like nine
and like knocked my door like oh jack
like you ready
i was not ready i was like at least i
was like
i felt like crying i was like so
emotional i was all over the place it
was like really i'd never
been like so bad it was really weird i
felt like very uncontrollable
and i was like can i use your phone i
think i need to speak to the like
therapist guy i was on the phone tim for
about
two hours i del i'd push back the whole
first day of filming
so much but they were like like amazing
they were honestly like
so good because look realistically i
think they knew i wanted to do it i
probably was gonna do it
i was having a serious moment they also
knew that my
mental health was in like a really bad
place at the time they were amazingly
understanding and kind of
patient with me and um
yeah there was this kind of one one
woman there who was like
he'd be the exec or like a producer
maybe the exact producer but she was
like my
go-to my go-to girl and
she made me do it because i said i spoke
to the therapist for ages and i was
still a bit like oh god
he gave me that very good thing of like
you know one step at a time he's like
get ready
go downstairs see how you feel next step
you know
you're ready when you get in the car and
get to the location
and see how you feel and like and it was
like that was like again there were like
words of wisdom to me at that point
so i was like i'm not gonna be able to
do it so i'm just thinking to the end of
the show i'm like how the hell am i
gonna do seven days
like a month like no way yeah say he's
like you know it's like one step at a
time like break it down and that
helped me so much and then yeah i was
just kind of with her and that is such
good advice i think for anybody that's
listening that
i mean pretty much in all facets of life
whether you're trying to achieve
something great or you're trying to
overcome fear
yeah breaking it down into smaller
manageable pieces
makes it absolutely yeah it was like a
game changer for me
like those simple yes but it just helps
you think in a different way
so yeah i was just kind of talking to
them talking down and i definitely i
said like calm down i
was just like hey do you know what yeah
obviously do it jack i didn't want to do
it like these things
just the show's crazy i want to give it
a go
like you know that piece of me is still
in me like ah
i wish i if it was more like oh i wish i
still had it me to
kind of do that was that right let's go
and
and yeah just kind of got on with it had
like very highs and lows in there
every time we finished the task i'd feel
literally like on top of the world
like everyone in there you know you just
accomplished something i never thought
i'd be able to do especially like with
how i was feeling
then when we're kind of going to a task
that's when i'd have the thing of oh
i'm gonna i want to pull out i want to
like leave and in the show you that's
the kind of point
you pull out when you've kind of reached
your
your limit and for me definitely for me
a bigger part
although physically i mean it was just
hell
like it was how i got like so hurt doing
it like everywhere
but for me it was definitely a way
bigger mental battle and i think
probably everyone in there would say the
same
because you are thinking i don't need to
do this
it doesn't matter if i get to the end or
not it doesn't actually really make a
difference to me
i really hit my limit about god it was
like four days in
i think it's like a seven day thing it
was like the fourth day
mentally i was like drained but also
i was like so physically hurt and had
like one injury that was like really
annoying me
but and i'm thinking yeah cool i'm gonna
get to tomorrow and see how i feel
if it like still really hurts as i was
at that point where i couldn't like
run it's more like a fast limp like
and we got like halfway through that day
we just played a game called murderable
which you can imagine it's really fun
yeah which involves being like rugby
tackled by tony bellew and stuff like
that so
after that i was like i'm done
but the thing that like made me like a
lot happy about it one i got further
than i ever thought especially the days
before it further than i
ever thought i'd got like i never
thought in a million years when i feel
like that i could
be able to achieve those kind of things
and it really showed me like you know if
you just commit
it's gonna make me feel so much better
like afterwards
if i stick through and just persevere
and then
at the same time i was like well i've
left after like completing something so
it's kind of like a
it was like a good sign off for me i
didn't get something and be like ah no
thanks
i'm gonna go so i kind of i was like
look i'm just gonna
do this one tick this off and then yeah
it's probably time to go because i can
feel like when they're like die now like
everything's in so much pain
and i was just like yeah i mean beyond
exhausted so
and you could be proud of yourself at
that point honestly like i was so happy
with
how far i got it was like uh you know
kind of had to be there
moment when you're going through all
that to understand how hard it is to do
that for that long but
like two people get together two people
got to the end of the show
so i was like yeah i was so happy with
how far i got and that
really made me like feel like just so
much better and it kind of showed me
like you know
just physical exercise everything like
that is so good for your like mental
health and so i carried on running after
that and like training
really hard because in the build up i
was training like twice a day for like
two months
quick one starting from the minute the
lockdown is lifted we're gonna start
bringing in some of our subscribers to
watch how this podcast is produced
behind the scenes
means you get to meet the guests meet
myself and see how we put all of this
together
if you want that to be you all you've
got to do hit the subscribe button
where are you at now in your life in
terms of career in terms of your mental
health in terms of
your personal situation yeah like mental
health i feel pretty good
like right now i definitely have my days
like about a month ago i had like
a weird week i was like trying to help
a friend who was going through it and
they but they well who would just
finally start talking about it and
didn't know
what was going on and i was just
explaining how it was with me
and it was like that was the first time
i spoke about it in like quite a while
so it just kind of made me
it just brings it all to just yeah
brings it service it made me feel a bit
like funny
for a few days but like to be honest
with you i think like i said a lot of my
problems were
when i was going to things and trying to
do something where i felt really like
uncomfortable kind of out of your
comfort zone
that's kind of a lockdown you just have
to be at home a lot so
i do definitely feel like comfortable
and i think it's been quite
good for my mental health and now when i
have the days where i go out and i've
got like you know
a day of like work or something i've got
to do loads of things i'm really happy
to kind of be out
sure and stuff so it's kind of like yeah
i think it's again are you nervous about
coming here
you're kind of releasing i wasn't you
know what i was nervous that i was gonna
get nervous about coming
so when it came to i was like oh i don't
want to get to the day and be like
yeah i don't i i feel a bit like weird
yeah i feel like honestly completely
fine like i said
i'd have you've probably heard no yeah i
would have problems
so i hear talking about lockdown i heard
you um
you got a little bit of relationship
over lockdown which is um
yeah seems a lot of a relationship yeah
we were talking about this before we
started recording yeah been with your
girlfriend now eight months how's that
going it's never easy it's going
incredibly well
to have a lockdown relationship yeah
it's definitely not
like easy having a lockdown relationship
but we also don't know
any anything else because we met like
the beginning of
last year what because we were neighbors
basically we were like
our apartments doors opposite each other
and i moved in
like the first week of march last year
so that's kind of like how we met
and she had a dog so there was lots of
dog walk dates basically
excuse me was it was it difficult
dating when you were um
really in your stride with youtube and
you had like i imagine you people were
stopping you a lot yeah stuff like that
and when you had the you know the stuff
on tv
yeah i didn't really date then to be
honest with you because
i'd like there was like two things one i
had in my hand of like you know i'm just
so
like focused on what i'm doing right now
and i
i didn't purposely not but i would i
didn't put much effort into you know it
wasn't really one of my priorities
whatsoever
and i was just having you know i was
enjoying i was like just living life i
was having so much fun
yeah and like all of my friends were
single as well so just i don't know just
didn't happen whatsoever there was no
need for me to do that but also my
brother got a girlfriend in his prime
of like his his career and i think he'd
you know be the first to say that it
i'm not saying this is for everyone at
all but my experience it like kind of
held him back not in terms of she held
him back but you know
just having a girlfriend you have
different priorities and different
focuses and stuff they're focusing on
their life
yeah so i just like didn't have any real
intentions what's been the upside of
having a partner
um because i'm a single guy so i'm like
asking i want you to pitch it to me
what's the
yeah people think people think are you
saying like it's so much happier
i feel i don't sound so like cringy but
i just feel like so much
happier i look at the days of when you
know
being single and like wanting to like go
out and do all these things and like
or like dating and stuff like i look at
it now like oh my god
so much like effort in a way where it's
now so like just fun and like
relaxing it's very nice to feel for
everyone listening to this but that
can't see him he's saying all this but
he's shaking his head
it's amazing definitely do it
but it's just like amazing being you
know so comfortable
with someone i think for me especially
that was like a massive thing because
i've been so uncomfortable in so many
situations
with like where i was at to then meet
someone and and be in those positions
where normally i would be
uncomfortable sounds kind of like cringy
but having her there makes me feel like
so much better without her even knowing
it just being with someone and whatever
makes you feel
you know so good and i've never had i've
never i've
actually never been in a relationship
really so this is kind of like my first
relationship
which i don't know if she likes or not
really you know if she likes it yeah so
as in like
the fact that it's my first relationship
sometimes she's like you know i wish
you'd maybe had a girlfriend before so
you'd know this or that and the other i
think she also likes the fact that
she's my first and why wouldn't someone
want to be you
um i think the main one i'd probably say
is there's like a lot of
pressure like but i'm the one putting
that pressure on myself no one's putting
pressure on me
but it's just a lot of like
self-pressure like i'm
in control of like everything i'm i said
it's a diary you're like ceo i'm like my
own boss i'm in control of everything i
do i'm in control of all my
finances like what comes in like what
goes out it's all just
kind of on me so if i stop you know it
all stops
if i work my hardest then you know
hopefully it kind of
pays off so it's just a lot of a lot of
pressure in terms of you know
wanting to keep going and like also
expand like taking like every
opportunity you can get that's why
you know i went from youtube and i did
radio and i was like i want to break
that barrier to tv and then i started
djing and
doing like music and going on tour and
all these things it was like just
grabbing every opportunity i can
to kind of grow as much as i possibly
can but it's
like exhausting it definitely takes a
toll and sometimes you do need to kind
of step
back but also like i said if i stop kind
of everything stops so taking a step
back is like
not possible yeah it's a bit of a risk
that carpet was it carpentry
yeah job you had when you were 16. just
sometimes you wish maybe
i'm like yeah because you know my dad
does fine for himself he's like three
kids and we've all turned out
like fine and we've all done well for
ourselves sometimes i feel like i would
be so much happier at that same time i'm
like
oh my god when i look back at some of
the things i've done in my life i'm like
that's amazing i'm like so proud of
myself for some of the things i've done
in the moment it felt pretty cool but
when i look back on it i'm like that was
like
huge and you're still so young yeah i'm
20 just
about yeah 26. taking all the pressure
off and i don't want to apply extra
pressure here
but when you look forward at your the
next i don't know 20 years of your life
how in your mind do you see that kind of
playing out i don't mean like i'm going
to be doing this exact thing but
like what are you looking for from life
um
i think i'm looking like being
completely honest with you it's kind of
like probably looking more into like
businesses and like business and having
like i said i've got my own like
production company right now that's
doing
probably way better than i thought it
was going to be doing at this point
which is good so like things like that
just growing it as much as i can and
you know kind of the classic i want to
be like a
boss and across so many things not that
i'm not working but you know
it's not like i've got a nine to five
type thing so it's kind of like
like i was doing youtube because i i
could kind of do whatever i wanted with
my days
but i knew i had to do likes kind of
things and and you know i'm still making
like
my money and everything like that and i
think yeah you know look at i'm probably
not going to be 30 years old
making like these kind of youtube videos
anyway who knows
but might be a niche for that yeah yeah
so it's like realistically i look at my
life probably like
trying to go into into that kind of
direction just
building something else well i'm looking
forward to seeing what you do next
i'm um i'm gonna be watching very very
closely now that i
stalk you on social media so and i think
like as i say you're like super young
but you have such a wealth of experience
from everything you've been through and
i don't think you know sometimes you
don't realize how how valuable some of
that experience has been until
until later in life and in fact i still
think about my hardest ever moment
starting a business as a young guy yeah
as being my um
some of my most traumatic moments as
being my most valuable because they like
yeah
yeah you have something that no one else
has right yeah you know and you have
experiences
thank you so much for coming today
yourself riveting and um right
you've been so honest as well which was
the whole point of this podcast at the
end of the day because i also know that
you've helped a lot of people by
walking us through your journey with
mental health with with you know and
with learning a bit more about it so
just want to say a huge thank you and um
if you ever do start a podcast
we'll do this again once yeah since i
can siphon it for your listeners but uh
but yeah thank you so much thank you
thank you
people ask me for book recommendations
all the time and i finally got one
for you it's a book called happy sexy
millionaire
which is authored by me there's this
crazy thing when you write a book
because
you spend so much time pouring your
heart and soul into it and everything
you know and all of the revelations
you've had in your life
and then there's this barrier which is
that people have to buy the thing in
order for them to get
that thing that means so much to you i
wish that wasn't the case
it's just the way the industry is and in
order to get that distribution and to
get it on shelves you need a publisher
so
please please please if you can if
you've ever liked anything i've
ever produced this podcast my instagrams
anything i've ever said
read this book there was no ghost writer
i wrote every single word myself there's
some real surprises in there it's an
honest
sometimes hilarious incredibly
vulnerable hopefully valuable
recount of my life my journey everything
i've learned across
across the way and really the answer to
being fulfilled to being happy and to
achieving success
it is the most important important thing
i've ever created so i implore you to go
to amazon now or wherever you get your
books
and get that pre-order if you get that
pre-order i'm gonna put you into a group
with everybody that's pre-ordered it
and i'm gonna send you some exclusive
stuff so the first things i'm gonna do
is a series of voice notes which i think
are
um are going to be pretty powerful i'm
going to give you access to some tickets
which nobody else will have
and i'm going to do everything i can to
thank you for for giving me that sort of
nine quid of your money or whatever it
is
happy sexy millionaire you can pre-order
it everywhere now and if you do get that
pre-order please do dm me because i'd
love to thank you myself
[Music]
you